[Music]
brand new fears iran-backed Hezbollah
will open a new front from the North in
Israel's war on terrorism Israeli forces
clashing with Hezbollah in Lebanon today
as the radical mulas of Iran refus to
back down following this warning from
Joe Biden we moved the US carrier Fleet
to the Eastern Mediterranean and we're
sending more fighter jets there in that
region and made it clear made it clear
to the Iranian
be careful so Martha even if the
administration won't talk much about it
Iran is key to this whole thing yeah it
was interesting um Bob Gates was on
America's reports this morning or
America's news J this morning and he
said every president who has extended
their hand to Iran has had it
slapped and that's exactly what we're
watching play out here because there was
an effort with the jcpoa um there was an
effort with this uh deal five for five
hostages plus $6 billion I I don't
understand I don't think we know the
answer yet to why they will not say that
Iran is obviously behind this attack
well we can't like Jack Keane General
Jack Keane said you know what are they
looking for like a signed piece of paper
that said yes please go in on October
7th they're not going to find that but
you know the general says it's obvious
that they would never have pulled this
off this orchestration without the
Iranians so I I think this is a story
that we're going to keep diing into and
find out why there is such reluctance to
refreeze the money and say that's what
you're I said to John Kirby today if you
if they requested he said oh they
haven't touched a dime of it over and
over and over again he said that yeah
but what if they asked for it tomorrow
if they ask her tomorrow would you would
you deny it and he wouldn't answer it
John Kirby was dancing today on your
show Jesse why why on the Iran question
she just ask well they're dealing with
China and Russia who back the Iranians
and so they're trying to put together
this deal with the Saudis and the
Israelis to normalize relations and the
other Arab partners and if Hezbollah
comes in with rockets from the north it
opens up a two front War and the United
States is screwed because the United
States is going to really have to go in
hard and Joe Biden doesn't want to touch
it Joe Biden should just bring in Turkey
he should bring in the Egyptians because
we pay those countries a lot of money
and he should work this out in a deal
and he can't do it because he's not
smart enough so he's going to probably
just watch it all happen as the rest of
this country watches it all happen and I
don't think it's going to end well yeah
Harold and judge you were a big debate
in the break uh it was a very lovely
conversation it was Spirited uh recreate
in 90 seconds no I mean if we do stand
back and watch Herold what happens I
don't think we should stand back and
watch I just think we need to be mindful
of what happens if something else
happens if this happens on the North uh
it's very likely we will find the
Israelis the Israelis have never asked
the Americans to be involved militarily
actively involved militarily with troops
as you well know Pete you're the only
one who serve at this table I think they
might the likelihood of them asking if
that happens on a North Front in
increases dramatically that's the only
point I make is we think about what
comes next I agree with the first part
of what you said and I agree totally
they should John Kerman everybody should
say we're freezing the funds say that I
understand that the dancing on some of
the other things but you got to say
you're freezing those funds Jud okay you
know when John Kirby danced today I
watch it we're watching it like a hawk
what does that mean John Kirby I
Jonathan I mean it's just it's stupid
watching it like a hawk um look here
here the problem obviously is that um if
they say Iran was at it behind it
everybody knows they were everybody
knows Iran backs Hamas and Hezbollah
then we put ourself in a footing where
we're possibly in a world war everybody
understands that so they're being
delicate about the language you know but
the truth is you know when Joe Biden
comes out and when uh Austin comes out
and says don't it reminds me of Nancy
Reagan when she just when she said just
say no to drugs you know it just it
doesn't work all right and it doesn't
show how firm we are I mean what about
this Hamas guy living in Cutter why
aren't we why aren't we sanctioning cter
for that guy over there who's behind
Hamas and all of this other stuff I mean
you know we're we're we're like a we're
like pushovers and we haven't shown any
strength in a in a neighborhood where
only strength is respected and that's
the problem yeah you're exactly right
for the record when Nancy Reagan told me
to just say no I did just say boy worked
on works on some hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
you YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else